try to go for the quick series sweep
tonight they sent julio urias to the
mount who said a few great starts this
season his last timeout though gave up
five runs against the angels
yeah a little hot and cold the overall
numbers are really good for julio but he
wants to get on a roll crawford stands
in 1-1 pitch
is popped up short left field turner's
out
curling around makes the catch in foul
ground one gun in this first inning up
comes mitch hannigan who had himself
quite a night last night slurve has
pulled in a bounce to
turner what a pay and he tosses across
muncie digs it out i mean this was a
rocket hit down to third base and on the
short hop
turner able to make a sensational play
two up two down for urias
and kyle lewis comes up he swings and
misses at a change up
and julio's got a one two three first
justin dunn 25 years old on a long
island in new york
opponents hitting just 174 against him
that's one of the best opponents
averages in baseball but the problem is
he's got the worst walk rate in the
sport bulky bats will lead things off
it's popped up
right side of the infield right near the
bag at third behind it evan white is
there
and makes the easy catch one gone here
in the first inning here's seeger
swinging a fly ball into center field
lewis backing up near the woody track
kyle is there a step out of the track to
make the catch
here's justin turner breaking ball
swinging a fly ball into right field and
deep hannigan going back near the track
he's there
and he makes the catch and that'll end
the inning so one two three bottom of
the first
for justin dunn three up three down for
both pitchers in the first kyle seeger
climbs in and swings at the first pitch
a seeger thing and there's brother corey
there to put it away
one pitch one out for uris in the second
four up four down for julio ty france to
the plate
that is a high fly ball left center
field chris taylor
moving to his left he's got it two gone
got him looking at another breaking ball
so
aureus with the strikeout that's his
second one
six up and six down for the mariners
muncie my goodness draws a walk
for the 35th time this year one out for
the dodgers and that'll bring up catcher
will smith
breaking ball swing animus for strike
three and dunn
goes with a 3-2 curveball and he strikes
out will smith his first strikeout
tonight
and the battle will be center fielder
chris taylor swing and a miss and a
curveball down and away for strike three
he came back with a 3-2 breaking ball
just like he did with smith
back-to-back strikeouts for justin dunn
and here's left fielder matt beatty
swung out on a fly ball into center
field but right there is kyle lewis
coming in now to make the catch
and that'll end the inning it's been six
up six down
from urea so far dylan moore leading off
here in the third
got him swinging here his third
strikeout and he's retired the first
seven
here's the eight hitter evan white good
morning good afternoon good night
fastball and a change and back-to-back
case
second career big league at bat for
justin dunn maria strikes out the side
of the third
second time through the order dodgers
still looking for their first hit
both teams looking for their first hit
of the night here's mookie
stroke to left center field that'll
split the gap
first hit of the game is a ringing
double for mookie bench
the runner in scoring position two men
out corey seeger
breaking ball swing on hit right side jp
crawford in the shift is right there
takes his time
throws over to evan white and that'll do
it for the dodgers in the third but nine
up nine down for aureus
he's struck out five including striking
out the side in order
in the third inning it's a jam shot in
the left that baby
white's making that one a little bit
more difficult on baby but he finds it
puts crawford away
one away for the mariners and that is 10
in a row retired by julio urias
swing and a miss on a chain jump and
aria says his 6th k
mariners team they got no hit by john
means one week ago tonight
off the end of the back foul grounded
first muncie
over mercy
makes the play leading against the
netting he's got it
and goes 12 up 12 down to start this
launch
dodgers threatening base has loaded one
down matt beatty
will try to get a run or two in here
baby hitting 412 with runners in scoring
position
drive bases all the way to the base of
the warning truck
it brings home two the dodgers break
through first on a two-run double from
matt beatty
maria's back to the mound 12 up 12 down
for the lefty who's doing it again to
these mariners
the one two broken bad roller
justin turner for the first round of the
fifth
that'll bring up second baseman ty
france swinging a shot
into the hole at short and through for a
base hit and the mariners have their
first hit off for julio
maria's tonight with one out here at the
top of the fifth inning
it was easy to start dreaming though
wasn't it in the scoring position goes
france
dylan moore the left fielders first
pitch in play looped into right field
for a base hit
france is coming around third and the
mariners are on the board dylan moore
wasted no time
to turn her aboard with two men out and
then get max muncie to the plate
the middle of this dodger lineup is
beginning to show some signs of the
busting out of the back spinning fly
ball
deep center field did he get it off you
bet he did
back-to-back games with a home run for
muncie
two-run shot 4-1 dodgers
four in a row have reached after vest
got the first two men of the inning
and it brings up matt baity who drove in
two last innings
and the score is smith and it's 5-1
five consecutive two out base runners
for the dodgers
sliced into left center field base hit
lux taylor into score
and the two-out beat goes on it's 6-1
julio aureus into the seventh inning
he's giving up just one run on two hits
and so so far this one's falling into
that
very distinct bucket of dominant starts
truly been one end of the spectrum or
the other with
urias this year bounce gently to third
turn awaits on it
gobbles it up and throws them out on
five
pitches a one two three seven through
rhys
tags and takes third aj [ __ ] as the
pinch hitter for matt beatty
on a line center field lewis lays
rbi single for aj [ __ ] the dodgers
lead it seven to one
nelson went one two three in the eighth
on the verge of a two-game sweep
got him more perfect relief work from
the dodgers tonight at six up six down
for jimmy nelson
and they've won back-to-back games
they've won a series for the first time
since
mid-april during the slop it was
starting pitchers only
and no offense no bullpen but now
they're starting to fire on all
cylinders they come up with a sweep